let's just jump right into uh the
difference between being a hedge against
inflation versus a hedge against loose
monetary policy forget bitcoin for a
second like what's the difference in
those two things because it's somewhat
nuanced but important sure so really the
difference is that policy reacts to
inflation so if you're trying to find
things that are
hedging against inflation you need
things that aren't going to be crushed
by policy so
risky assets generally get crushed when
policy reacts to inflation
whereas certain other things um like
commodities and bonds
10 or short you have to be short bonds
of course as an inflation hedge
tend to
work even when policy reacts so
what you get essentially is two waves
you get the loose policy which is what
we had extremely loose policy uh fiscal
and monetary
and that drives the price of all assets
up but the highest beta or the the most
volatile assets
are the most risky assets so
you know ethereum bitcoin um and then
after that you had like nasdaq stocks
meme stocks uh all that kind of stuff
reacts the most to loose monetary policy
and there's a whole bunch of
vectors for transmission i mean one of
them is just sentiment
um there's you kind of get this panic to
the top side essentially but then what
happens is eventually the policy makers
have to react to the inflation and
tighten monetary policy
so then that's when the rubber hits the
road on on whether something's an
inflation hedge or not so things like
commodities or short bonds have
continued to perform well as the fed has
tightened
uh whereas obviously bitcoin and and
more speculative assets have performed
poorly
so what i'm talking about here is a
cyclical thing and then um what a lot of
people believe is a more structural
thing which is that
loose monetary policy which you i would
just say mmt is kind of like the basic
framework which is
a very loose fiscal
and it's kind of um
aided and embedded by monetary so
that's kind of like the the primary
framework like the old keynesian thing
where you you stimulate when things are
bad and then you pull back fiscal when
things are good that's kind of gone in
the garbage and now it's a lot more like
about mmt so that started with like the
tcga which was trump's tax cut um in the
in the at the peak which is extremely
unusual totally unheard of um and
continued with the coveted response
so i think there's also this structural
element of you know these things like
bitcoin as as a hedge will work in the
long run because
money is being debased
you know in but then that's a structural
thing and then you got to watch out for
the cycles which obviously the cycles
can be nasty
and
i'm not saying this in hindsight so like
i was writing about this in november of
2021
that like the party's pretty much over
as you know the inflation and
like loose policy and raging inflation
is like mana for risky assets and for
for things like bitcoin and but then
when eventually policy reacts with the
lag then you gotta watch out so i think
the some i mean some people would i know
someone responded on twitter yeah like
thanks for the update obviously this is
like i can see the prices on the screen
um and i mean that's certainly fair to
some extent but i don't think it's
totally fair because
lots of people were making this
observation including me um in november
so
it's not it's not all hindsight and also
i do think there's an importance or a
usefulness to understanding
the current cycle so that the next cycle
you understand it better
julie no i was going to say like where
where do you think we're headed from
here because as you pointed out this is
something you were writing about back in
november where are we headed
so
i'm like very cautiously
optimistic now like i'm a little bit
more bullish crypto but definitely not
raging bullish
there's a few things so one is that the
terminal rate which is like how high is
the fed going to go
is pretty high now in terms of what the
market expects so
the room for rates to go higher to me is
pretty limited
unless you got like another full-on
subsequent inflation shock which i don't
think we'll get which would mean like
probably that would mean oil to 150 or
something like that which is not my base
case so i'm consciously optimistic
because i think we're kind of around
peak
fed
but then
you know just the way i was saying you
got to separate the cyclical from the
structural you also have to separate
the endogenous from the exogenous so
crypto has been getting hit by exogenous
which is external forces which is macro
higher real rates tightening policy
essentially like the inverse of the fiat
d basement trade right so
people correctly saw crypto and
specifically bitcoin as a fiat
debasement hedge and that was true but
then if the fed hikes real rates from
minus one to plus one you know fiat
debasement isn't really a thing as much
anymore because
fiat currency has positive um you know
positive value in theory um
so
the question now is
okay if that exogenous shock is done
which i kind of think it is like i think
the fed's close to probably peak
although i will just say one quick
little caveat there
is that the fed tends to always fight
the last war so that's what you got with
flexible average inflation targeting was
they failed to to get inflation up for
so long that they finally like said okay
screw it we're all in
and of course that was the worst
possible timing
so now they're going to be fighting the
last war again which is they're going to
be scared of inflation the politics of
inflation are bad it makes the fed look
bad they're hurting credibility-wise
so i don't think it's going to be like
2018 2019 where they just went from like
hiking to cutting
my feeling is probably they just stay on
hold for ages once they find their happy
place
um so that's the exogenous story which
is like getting better but it's not
amazing but then you have this
endogenous which is like the internal
factors of crypto
which i think is like
maybe reaching a crescendo around now um
and it comes down to liquidations right
like 3ac and and all that stuff
um so like i've been dabbling for
example in gbtc
because like the biggest holder of gbtc
is is 3ac and
so i'm guessing there's going to be some
force liquidation there that's part of
probably why
the the discount has widened so far um
so i believe in the structural crypto
story as i think
mmt i'm like completely insane
fiscal and monetary policy in tandem is
like the base case for the next 20 years
but then i am more of a trader so i tend
to like ride the cycles as well
and so i feel like if you're riding the
cycle from the short side like short
ethereum or whatever that trades over
and now it's more like i don't think
it's the raging bull scenario either i
think it's more like you dabble you pick
your spots
and
you know if you're an investor
or you're looking for like long-term
debasement uh insurance in your
portfolio you know buying bitcoin from
here down to 10k makes a ton of sense to
me
and honestly like i don't know if you
want to go into it but to me most almost
every other like
altcoin and i would include ethereum
obviously not as an altcoin but i would
include ethereum as
i feel like those are just a completely
different category and
they might not work as as fiat
debasement hedges they might just all go
to zero